So, how do we do this
with other decimals?
Once we know how to state the number,
we can make the conversion.
Let's look at these three decimals.
How would we talk about these numbers?
Well I'd say three-tenths,
nineteen-hundredths, and
two-hundred-and-eleven-thousandths.
The number written in purple
becomes the numerator, and
the word written in green
becomes the denominator tenths.
This becomes nineteen-hundredths and
this becomes
two-hundred-and-eleven-thousandths.
So what is the equivalent fraction
of eighty-one-hundredths?
Write your answer here with
the numerator up on the top, and
the denominator down on the bottom.